meteorologists say the active wildfire
season is being fueled by unusually dry
conditions
the west needs to wean itself off
russian oil and gas now beyond the
humanitarian catastrophe of the war
itself that's a clear consequence
of the war in ukraine for neighbouring
countries despite the uk not importing
as much oil and gas from russia as other
countries enormous amounts of our money
has gone there in recent years
since the 2014 annexation of crimea the
united kingdom has paid russia more than
22 billion pounds for oil and gas
imports according to one analysis now
that's enough money according to oxford
university academics to pay for more
than 8 000 t14 russian tanks
but the analysis found that if the uk
implements the net zero measures
recommended by the climate change
committee then we could end imports of
russian gas as early as 2023
and oil imports by 2024.
now those measures include ensuring that
cars and vans are electric by 2030
decarbonizing the electricity grid by
2035
and by expanding woodland cover in the
uk by 5
by 2050 to help absorb carbon
one of those who did the analysis is
cameron hepburn director of the smith
school of enterprise and the environment
at the university of oxford earlier i
asked him how we'd manage if we needed
to turn off russian oil and gas right
now
oil and gas are traded in global markets
so if we turned off russian suppliers
immediately i think we could more i mean
not quite immediately but we could more
or less do that by finding supplies
elsewhere but of course if the whole
world tries to go off russian oil and
gas
at the same time we'd be in a bit of
trouble so
it's a complicated question in the short
run but actually if you look at the
question over more medium or long term
uh it's abs it's perfectly possible for
us to wean ourselves off russian oil and
gas and indeed eventually oil and gas
all together
well yes and we'll talk about medium and
long term in a moment but what about
short term because a lot of people might
say if you're going to stop getting oil
and gas from russia isn't the immediate
solution to increase your domestic oil
and gas production
basically drill more in the north sea
yeah i've heard that a lot the problem
is it's not as if you can just kind of
turn the taps on uh that quickly you you
can obviously make uh some change in the
short run but it's not going to um you
know substitute the entirety of russian
supply in that kind of period i mean in
a sense the fastest thing we could do if
we're really serious
about helping the ukrainians is turn our
thermostats down i mean a rapidly
reducing demand
we can do rapidly increasing supply and
drilling for new oil and
gas in new wells is not not quite as
fast
so talk to us about those measures those
medium to long-term measures then to try
to cope without these imports what can
we do
yeah well if we if we don't just turn
our thermostats down which in the medium
long term we don't want to do if we do
that in the short term and reduce our
demand by about what russia is supplying
if we reduce thermostat by a degree but
in the medium to long term i mean simply
a question of following the climate
change committee's balanced net zero
pathway we do that
then we take uh fossil fuel demand down
by about third over the course of this
the rest of this decade we'd be
completely off russian oil and gas by
about 2024
and so we just actually have to do what
we plan to do
with the green transition and and in a
sense this problem resolves itself now
the big unspoken challenge here the the
question that isn't asked enough is how
are we managing our energy storage
this is a key question for gas at the
moment will become a key question when
we move to a renewable system as well
and we're going to have to manage energy
storage in the winter when the sun isn't
shining and the wind isn't blowing as
much
and that presumably requires investment
as does the investment in electric car
infrastructure in rolling out more
renewable provision as well i mean this
is going to be costly isn't it
it is but you know we've spent 22
billion pounds since 2014 when the
russians annex crimea just on oil and
gas from russia and we could save 70
billion pounds between now and 2030 if
we follow this net zero balanced pathway
that 70 billion pounds can go into the
sort of investments in the clean
technologies and the clean energy system
that would then offset the need to be
buying all of this oil and gas in the
first and what about some of our
neighbors some european countries rely
much more heavily on russian gas
particularly as well as its oil is there
a risk that some countries will turn to
increase coal production to try to make
up the shortfall as they start to wean
themselves off russian oil and gas yup
you're quite right on both counts they
do germany for instance relies much more
heavily on russian gas and i think yes
you're right but in the short term we
will see and we are seeing
greater coal use to be honest now
in the medium to longer term though i
think
this current crisis horrid though it is
terrible though it is in the human cost
is likely to be a good thing for the
transition to clean energy because we'll
see as you say increasing coal burn in
the short term
but in the long term what this does is
trigger greater investment in renewable
energies their costs continue to fall
and this transition we think happens
faster than it otherwise would have as a
result of this war not that you would
ever have wished for the war
with the world changing so rapidly
adaptation is key in our latest climate
diary we head to the tip of south
america where scientists have armed a
passenger ferry with technology which is
the first of its kind in the southern
hemisphere its job to provide key data
in order to help the region adapt to the
warming climate
organisms
[Music]
[Music]
do stay with us coming up i'll be joined
by the chief executive of forum for the
future dr sally uran and the executive
director of climate outreach jamie clark
and we'll be discussing how to keep
climate action on the agenda and whether
we're ready to adapt to the new normal
brought on by global warming
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet if they do they fear they'll be
killed
[Applause]
[Music]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be in the danger zone
[Music]
these traffic jams snake for hours up
and down this hillside it means pressure
they can't access those and knees
[Music]
you can see the depth of water if you
have a look in front of us there are
people wading through it
i think experiencing the two million
person march in hong kong that was a
moment
[Music]
i don't like the chinese government it's
true
it was real people power in action
police have been firing tear gas and
rubber bullets
see fires all around us here and just
one of them is the size of around 31 000
football pitches
shiborn robbins sky news bangkok
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with the
chief executive of forum for the future
dr sally youren and the executive
director of climate outreach jamie clark
so very good evening to both of you nice
to see both
so the war in ukraine has dominated our
airwaves for weeks for entirely
understandable reasons and as an energy
supply crisis picks up steam the steep
rise in the cost of living is going to
affect us all
but the urgency of dealing with the
climate crisis hasn't gone away so how
then to break through what's the best
way of communicating the urgency of the
climate challenge while people are
focusing on other things
jamie you're a communications specialist
so what how do you make sure that the
message about climate change does
continue to resonate when people are
really concerned about paying their
bills about the cost of living crisis
and they're really worried when they
hear horrendous stories about a war in
europe yeah it can be a big challenge
communicating climate change has
historically been
something that's been difficult to do
but actually we know that the public in
the uk are massively concerned about
climate change
at the end of last year it was the
number one priority now in the recent
research we at climate out which i said
i have undertaken it's in the top four
and the issue is that people can see the
relationship to these global problems
and the cost of living when renewables
are the cheapest form of energy and we
know we need to insulate our homes to
save energy
actually climate action can be central
to supporting the move away from russian
oil and gas and reducing the cost of
living for those of us who are really
pushed to pay our bills
sally do you agree with that do you
think that people do see that bigger
picture or do you think there are some
that think i've got more immediate
concerns and anyway when we hear about
net zero we hear about targets and goals
around 2050 we've got time to think
about that in the future
yeah i mean it is a conundrum isn't it
and i think the first thing i would say
is that
talking about climate change isn't a
luxury it's a necessity and i think we
just need to keep pointing to the facts
and the figures that say if we tackle
climate change meaningfully right now if
we accelerate the shift to renewable
energy we will start to save money so
actually tackling climate today is a way
of dealing with cost of living rises
tomorrow
do you think that that message gets
through jamie the fact that renewables
are cheaper in the long term and a good
way of replacing
the russian oil and gas because this
other argument that does keep coming up
is well if we're not getting those
imports of russian oil and gas why don't
we just drill more at home why don't we
drill more in the north sea
yeah we do we do know that facts and
figures are really important but also
the social science proves that it's
actually
more about values and emotions when we
have these difficult dilemmas of what is
a priority but we know that for people
in this country they've experienced
floods they've experienced heat waves
and vulnerable people in their community
have been impacted so we do need to
relate these crisis to the real life
stories of what climate change is
impacting but also the benefits
so we can see the employment benefits of
of bringing in onboard renewables that
are going to happen much quicker than
any other technology we can see the
benefits of weaning ourselves off fossil
fuels that we know are associated with
totalitarian regimes like russia but
also other states that the british
public really feel uneasy about
taking money and oil and gas and giving
money to these organizations so yes we
need to keep the facts and figures in
there but these are real stories um
about the impact of climate change and
the positive solutions and how they can
make a difference in our communities has
to be central to the climate
conversation and having the climate
conversation is a real driver for action
we know that politicians sit up and
listen when they they know their
constituents care about these issues
we've seen what happened when gritter
thunberger and her
supporters got really active and changed
the way that governments acts on these
things so we need to have conversations
in our in our communities in our
workplace about why we care and then
others will realize that this is a
something that we can act on and why it
is a positive step forward on the cost
of living and a positive step forward
for action on ukraine
and suddenly a lot of the conversation
is about what governments can do we're
waiting for this energy security
strategy to come out with the
government's plans but do you think
people do feel more engaged when they
feel they have some agency when they
feel as a consumer as an individual they
can make a difference as well
absolutely and i think this is another
opportunity to really reinforce the
message that there's so much that we as
individuals can do so we know that if we
have a rapid switch to renewable energy
it will affect positively the cost of
living rise but even today as people are
grappling with re retrofitting their
homes and thinking about alternative
energy sources there are things we can
ask ourselves so where is our pension if
we're lucky enough to have pensions
lucky enough to have savings where is
that money invested just asking those
questions and really putting pressure on
those big financial institutions means
that actually you're sending a very
positive message so what and how we buy
the choices we make has incredible power
and leverage on big institutions which
again sends that positive signal that
this is the change that we want to see
okay let's move on to our next topic
shall we because it's getting hotter not
today perhaps but the met office has
announced that it's raising the
temperature at which a heat wave is to
be measured across certain counties in
england now a degree here and there
doesn't sound like much but it's the
result of the gradual warming of the
planet so what does this mean for us
should we be thinking more carefully
about adapting to extreme heat and sadly
first of all the official definition of
heat wave then changing for for a number
of counties in this country
so a reminder that climate change is
happening now and it's happening in this
country
it is i'm i'm afraid even if we
decarbonized immediately tomorrow the
impacts of climate change are with us so
there are some impacts already baked in
and i think that's why we need to talk
more about climate adaptation so yes we
need to
really rapidly decarbonaze but as we do
that we need to understand what can we
do to adapt to a changing climate and
that's where again there are
possibilities because actually climate
change impacts particularly elevated
temperatures they impact human health so
where are those intersections between
climate and health that allow us to
drive co-benefits for both so how we
think about how we lay down our
infrastructure how we put our housing
stock into place how we heat our homes
the choices we make about how we um
supply manufacturing energy these could
also have benefits for climate but also
for health and so we really need to get
serious about adaptation and understand
how can we adapt for a changing climate
in a way that also protects public
health
and jamie do you think there's enough
debate on the subject of adaptation in
this country we hear a lot about
mitigation don't we about trying to cut
back on fossil fuels for example to to
to reduce emissions but is there as much
focus do you think on adaptation should
there be more
no interestingly for the last few years
there hasn't been a great deal of focus
on it possibly because we haven't seen
the floods hitting london where which is
often drives the media stories that we
had previously but also because we're
making relatively good strides towards
mitigation we've still got more to do
we've got
a lot more renewables that we could
bring on board and insulation that would
really help in that respect
but the reality is it is hard baked in
now climate change we can we can make it
less serious but we are still
experiencing those um horrible realities
and in different ways and the met
offices
um
changing of the the heat levels in which
we we see a heat wave has been defined
is an important alarm bell to raise but
now we need to act on it and i think
that happened needs to happen at all
levels of society actually as us as
individuals in our homes we need to be
thinking about what does it mean for the
summer for uh the heat waves to get
hotter
and more likely to impact us we know in
2018 for example 700 people
[Music]
died from the extra heat those are
vulnerable peoples in their homes and
how can we protect ourselves how can we
protect others around us whether that's
putting shading over our windows having
cool areas of our houses but that's us
as individuals but actually the
governments and corporations can really
make a difference if it's house builders
how do they do that yeah so so many
questions which i'm sure we'll visit
again another time but we are out of
time for now jamie clark dr sally young
thanks very much indeed uh for your
debate tonight we appreciate it
so that's all for today joining me
tomorrow will be the professor in energy
and climate governance at the university
of lancaster rebecca willis and director
of international climate policy at the
nature conservancy john verdick
and do stay tuned because next will be
common ground on the show trevor
phillips is going to be asking if it's
time to put net zero on hold thanks for
watching i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
foreign